PIETRANGELO TAKEN TO THE BOARDS
BY LANDESKOG.
GRAVES WITH THE PUCK.
STEPHENSON LOOKING FOR IT.
GRAVES SENDS IT AHEAD
NICHUSHKIN.
GRAVES WITH IT AGAIN.
PACIORETTY COMES AWAY WITH THE
PUCK.
AHEAD FOR STONE.
MARK STONE MOVING IN ON
GRUBAUER.
HE SHOOTS!
HE SCORES!
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS WIN GAME 5 50
SECONDS INTO OVERTIME!
>> Brian: REMEMBER, MARK STONE
HAD THE GREAT CHANCE LATE IN
THIRD PERIOD.
FOR VEGAS.
AND HE BURIES THIS ONE IN
OVERTIME.
SHOT BLOCKS.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT IT THIS
SERIES.
GRAVES HAS ONE CHANCE.
IT'S BLOCKED BY STONE.
A SECOND ONE IS BLOCKED.
AND PACIORETTY GETS IT UP TO
STONE.
AND WATCH STONE JUST BURY IT TOP
SHELF RIGHT OVER THE GLOVE OF
PHILIPP GRUBAUER.
>> Eddie: THE RIGHT-HAND SHOT.
THAT'S THE SPOT.
THAT'S THE SPOT THAT'S OPEN.
IF YOU'RE COMING DOWN THAT LEFT
SIDE.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO ELEVATE IT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT STONE
WAS ABLE TO DO.
LOOK AT THE GLOVE POSITIONING OF
GRUBAUER.
IT'S DOWN LOWER.
THE LONG REACH OF STONE.
YOU'VE GOT SOME HAPPY TEAMMATES
AFTER THAT.
>> Brian: THERE'S NO BETTER
FEELING THAN TO BE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PILE OF THAT.
WHAT A SHOT.
OFF THE CROSSBAR AND IN.
PRESSURE COMING FROM GRAVES.
MACKINNON WAS COMING.
>> Eddie: I THINK STONE
RECOGNIZED, THAT BOUCH.
HE HAD PRESSURE.
AND HE KNEW HE HAD TO LET IT GO.
BUT IT WAS JUST THE TIMING PLAY
OF THE CAPITAL VN.
THE EMOTIONAL LEADER.
ON THE ICE INSIDE THAT LOCKER
ROOM.
AND THE FIRST EVER CAPITAL VN OF
THE VEGAS GOLDEN KNIGHTS.
ENDS GAME 5 IN OVERTIME.
50 SECONDS IN.
HOW ABOUT THE CHANCE BY COMPHER?
IT'S THE 10-SECOND MARK OF
OVERTIME.
THE SAVE BY FLEURY.
BOUCH, YOU TALKED AUT HIM
BOUNCING BACK.
AFTER GIVING UP THE SOFT GOA